décrit comme très bien et audio sur god
of war un jeu d'horreur fait partie
c'est un fait d'horreur dans lequel tout
change autour de nous voilà son
explication ça vous plaît ça j'aimerais
bien l'étape ce que je sens que la
maison va finir en feu je peux à bruges
le sens locked uni de kay donc en jeu
m'accroupir ça saute c'est parfait où
est la clé peut-être là dedans c'est là
que tout peut changer d'ère nous c'est
ça qui est très troublant ce [ __ ] de
jeu tu devrais toujours fermé les portes
derrière toi le but s'est échappé a bien
évidemment une nouvelle port
il faut fermer les ports d achat pour
progresser attention 55 ans vient de
donner leur aval respecter bonnes
grosses maisons dans les bois comme on
les aime à la fin que les a pas trouvés
allemand plus tard le coût du tout dormi
classé jeu classique one on l'appelle
dans le milieu des bilans wall est une
clé [ __ ] je trouve une [ __ ] de clés
à la hyène porte on l'avait pas vu la
vilaine a été bien caché un look aide
bah voilà bah oui tu commences bien de
le bloquer mais je sais de l'ouvrir
entrer un peu beauf cette insulte nos
est du coup quelle est cette source evry
sétois radi qui fait ça ne serait pas un
radis je tape les radis donc là à mon
avis et l intro et là qu'on va revenir
au top tout aura changé
est-ce que j'ai raison pas du tout
peut-être qu'il faut inspecter la carte
pour réaliser un petit peu sa géographie
et bien s'y connaître non j'ai froid mon
dieu je te porte de ma chambre mais ce
qui veut dire qu'un spectre où se trouve
pas loin d'un betty jean castex qu'en
jouant son jeu de rôle la yam petits
dégâts des dauphins constat s'il vous
plaît voilà on s'occupe comme on peut
pas servir de cette pelle pour déjà
s'assommer et mourir mais oui tu mets en
eau à la bouche et elle a bougé c'est la
brenaz point qu elle a bougé je vous le
dis alors vous vous êtes peut-être perdu
puisque je vais des coupures mais moi je
suis pas perdu et shekels à bouger un
faut pas prendre pour un con hein mais
du coup il ya quand même pas de porte
dedans mais mais que demande le peuple
c'est trade c'est un placard à la base
du cou des fois je suis contacté le
court encore un dégât des eaux faut
faire raconte ça je voudrais faire un
constat on s'en va des paquets pour une
culée [ __ ] une note
elle ne dit rien c'est à moi de l'écrire
parce que je vais écrire ma propre
histoire je écrire mon avenir après
m'être gratter le nez est-ce que des
fois tu as l'impression d'avoir pris le
mauvais chemin
on va chier on voit rien voir rien
il y avait de quoi une eau au monde 2
watts a fait à ça donne un peu la gerbe
s'agrandit alors là par contre je rigole
plus du tout ménard d'accès des bougies
si tu le fais avec ses débouchés j'y
crois pas dire amants se passer des
bougies at on toutefois cohérent et là
y'a quoi il ya du brouillard partout ça
fait bien là qu'est mon pc j'adore mais
ça c'est quoi c'est un monstre ou pas
j'ai peur de mourir en fait donc je vais
pas y aller à la porte et veut pas se
fermer mais si je vous avais dit fermer
les portes pour m'aider alors fait en
sorte que je puisse m'aider moi même
j'avoue mais n'est pas beaucoup fdp de
narrateur à inexistant mais je pense
qu'il faut aller par là bas mais c'est
surtout peur bec bienvenus mais du coup
j'ai trouvé la porte qui est fermée faut
une clé ou non aimé vous mes livres à
mon avis la clé peut-être dans un livre
un truc à la con comme ça il doit ya
voir aller
vivre quelque part dans la vienne et en
lui de ne pourrait ouvrir l'app à quoi
je ne vais pas bien longtemps cette
région c'est très sournois ouais c'est
ouvert et maintenant que se passe-t-il
nous et maintenant que se passe-t-il
cette planche volé sept pages volées on
est d'accord t'as j'ai besoin devient
fou donc ça valait bien la vas-y tu vas
au plafond on fais toi plaisir et a pas
de problème je m'en fous en foot c'est
pourquoi mais c'est ainsi au lac et al
comment est assez de l'état est ce que
tu t'es déjà caché dans un dressing non
assène youtube devrait faire oui je
ressort par l'autre ce qui est grave on
joue deux voudrait ouvrir une porte
alors il ya quoi dans cette première
porte à gauche il n'y a rien au ces
fermes et tu as besoin d'une clé aux 8
alors le plus est si je suis dit je suis
fier ça de fierté personnelle je mettrai
sur mon cv de youtube heures oh mon dieu
oh mais juste lé mais rien n'était la
[ __ ] de clé est aidée à des livres et
c'est bien ce que je disais c'est un
point qui affiche qui dit aimer vous mes
livres howie se déverrouille gérer dans
cette caisse comme si lui fait tout noir
fin de la démo merci à voir jouer c'est
le terme que je suis actuellement
psychologiquement j'ai acheté jeu j'ai
tout refait pour ouvrir cette [ __ ]
porte et me dites pas que là ça dit je
termine et je ne vous crois plus
monsieur non non aux achats tests y
avait une suite quand j'ai dit qu'on
terminera ce dieu sait qu on le
terminera observée sur ce bout de bois
mais c'est très dangereux ce qui se
passe là un un bout de bois et je suis
tombé dans le vide se trouve là il ya du
sol en fait on va le tenter
y'avait pas de sol faut aller où
une chaîne non non ça tombe sur soi peut
appeler vas-y de [ __ ] mais c'est une
épreuve pour être admis au cirque
d'hiver ou quoi entre toi et moi je te
merde tu le sais tu le sais je le sais
douce
ce matin j'ai joué à uden flore et je
n'aurais pas dû parce que c'était très
énervant laissant du coup mais bon
maintenant quand vous allez dans la vie
il faut y aller parfois c'est pourquoi
j'ai acheté le jeu pour appuyer torture
pareil je veux tu me restait à la démo
je ne comprends pas l'intérêt de cette
phase métaphorique du jeu voilà si je
peux me permettre c'est de la grosse
merde maintenant
obiwi y avait plus haut
mais l'on sait natyam la queue pour
sauter sociaux se joue au haut n'ont
surtout pas reculer mon garde ces
dernières portent mon casque il est où
il est où il est là ça descend ça des
soeurs et ça revient c'est fini c'est
fini c'est la faim prend ma bougie avec
toi on passe par cette porte aux cours
avec la bougie dans la main on s'en fout
au [ __ ] et bien dans le noir le trou
qui compliqua dans le jeu je passe par
dessus cette table basse ou est inclus
où est la clé beach foot réunis mais je
chie sur ce jeu me fait chier sur ce
[ __ ] ma douce et belle clé aïe je
t'aime en ce jour si périlleux je
déclare vouloir une clé plus que jamais
la clé ma revue et elle est partie en
courant à sa lutte puisque je vous dis
que j'ai trouvé la clef lé damon duel
écoutons le meilleur est le seul a plus
aucun sens mais je la prends quand même
je la refais un parce qu'il faut
refermer les pros mon dieu un tableau
qui touchera en foot tout ce qui se
passe je fais dire ce jeu et louis il
est vrai j'ai fini wooden flore en
janvier 2015 au run ah mais moi comme un
débile je cours vers les morceaux de
bois et qui forme une bouche pour doit
se taper ça à chaque fois qu'on pourra
passer de [ __ ] de bouts de bois
non mais j'en peux plus oh when the
sheep without l'aisne
j'aime la laine je suis mort de sa mère
le stock squeeze finissait la soirée
seul en position foetale son casque
s'envola sans raison il pleurait encore
plus forts seuls dans cette triste
chambre lorsque soudainement le casque
revient revient le prince quizy
s'agrippe s'agripper s'envole s'envole
vers d'autres cieux [ __ ] de bordel
[Musique]